I've been hearing about hillsdale my
entire life when i visited i fell in
love with the place
it's intangible but there's just
something about himself that really was
attracted to me i had the opportunity
really to interact with a lot of
different people i have my kind mega
sisters I got involved in the collegian
as I've been thinking about it I come
back to the time i spent writing for the
collegian it was just a really fun
experience my first real class or had
the opportunity to study US Supreme
Court cases was a constitutional law
class until it was the first time I
really read the cases and thought about
the impact in a negative way that
judicial activism can have learning the
history of the Court's decisions and how
it really changed the country during the
times when the court was dominated by
folks who didn't respect the rule of law
it made a huge impact on me in terms of
looking ahead to be a lawyer i had run
for supreme court in 2008 i became
interested in running for Supreme Court
again when the legislature changed it to
a nonpartisan race and so I got
interested again and decided to run Iran
against four opponents and a five-way
race ended up winning forty percent of
the vote
i'm looking forward to being a leader on
the court my approach is to follow the
rule of law rather than decide how a
case ought to turn out and reason
backwards from there when I learned I
was receiving this award I was surprised
my parents I think both won the award
but I never really considered myself a
candidate for it so i was very
pleasantly surprised
hillsdale college instilled in me a real
commitment i think the service
whether it be public service or service
to your family or to an institution or
where you're going to go to work been
lucky to watch the college grow and
change since i graduated in nineteen
eighty-seven now and the transformation
has been incredibly positive incredibly
inspiring i'm really proud to be a
wholesale grant